Salut !
Voici enfin le quatrième épisode,
pour débloquer une compétence
directement dans votre cerveau.
Au début j'avais prévu aujourd'hui,
de faire une compétence
de mentalisme.
Mais dans la vidéo des agents secrets,
si vous l'avez pas vu regardez la.
Il s'est passé ça dans
la section commentaires.
ça apparaît là devant moi.
Vous n'êtes même pas
d'accord entre vous.
Alors qu'on soit bien d'accord.
Il est évident que
pour le Canada-Espagne
c'était une blague,
du second degré.
Mais en vrai,
pour le troisième drapeau.
Je n'ai clairement
pas du tout cette section là,
de la culture générale en moi.
Donc je me suis dit pourquoi
ne pas trouver mon système
pour retenir les drapeaux ?
Et en même temps
faire en sorte que vous aussi,
vous connaissiez les drapeaux
à la fin de cette vidéo.
Parce que je vous rappelle
quand même,
le but de cette série de vidéos,
c'est qu'à la fin du visionnage,
vous ayez vraiment débloqué ça,
dans votre tête juste
en regardant la vidéo.
C'est tout il n'y a
rien d'autre à faire.
Donc c'est parti,
on télécharge tout ça
directement dans nos têtes
en une dizaine de minutes.
Et pensez à vous abonner,
à activer la cloche
pour ne pas rater
le prochain épisode,
qui sera donc débloquer une technique
de mentalisme dans votre tête.
Téléchargement des drapeaux
dans le cerveau.
Loïc générique !
Apprends les drapeaux
avec Fabien Olicard !
Je m'appelle toujours Fabien Olicard,
mettez un like à cette vidéo.
La seule chose
qu'on va utiliser aujourd'hui,
c'est de la mnémotechnique.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que la mnémotechnique,
ça va aller piocher dans des données
qui existent déjà dans nos têtes,
donc on va juste faire
une connexion entre des neurones.
Sans s'embêter à rentrer
de nouvelles données.
Et on va d'ailleurs
se concentrer sur un truc,
sur la reconnaissance
des drapeaux.
En gros, on voit un drapeau et boum
on sait dire de quel pays il vient.
Le but c'est d'avoir
une culture générale,
qui vous sert
et qui me sert au quotidien.
Voir un drapeau, et donc vouloir
savoir de quel pays il vient,
ça me semble plus pratique
et quotidien que une situation,
où il y a Jean-Jacques qui dit :
"Dessine moi le drapeau
de la Slovénie maintenant".
ça ça arrive quand même
moins souvent.
On va commencer par les drapeaux
des pays frontaliers de la France.
Et pour se rappeler quelles
sont nos frontières terrestres
avec la France métropolitaine,
il faut se souvenir
d'un mot ou d'un nom.
ISABELA M.
ça, c'est mon moyen
mnémotechnique
pour avoir la première lettre
de chaque pays,
qui a une frontière terrestre
avec la France métropolitaine.
Donc ISABELA M,
ça fait Italie, Suisse,
Allemagne, Belgique, Espagne,
Luxembourg, Andorre et Monaco.
Evidemment, on va aller
plus rapidement sur ces drapeaux là,
parce qu'on les
connaît déjà pas mal.
Et le but c'est juste de ne plus
jamais avoir de doute
quand on les voit
au milieu d'autres drapeaux.
L'Italie c'est facile,
c'est comme la France.
Donc c'est normal,
on est voisin.
Donc je me dis Italie
comme la France.
Donc trois bandes pareilles.
Et après je me dis,
on part du pesto pour finir en bolo.
C'est hyper cliché,
mais les clichés c'est ancré
dans le cerveau donc c'est parfait.
Donc vert,
comme le pesto au début
et ça finit en rouge
comme de la bolo.
Et si on veut pousser, entre les deux
il y a de la crème fraîche.
Suisse c'est la croix blanche,
qui est parfaitement équilibrée.
La croix donc un carré.
Et en Suisse,
les choses sont carrées,
c'est bien réglé et si c'est pas
bien réglé on voit rouge.
Voilà comment
on va juste se rappeler de ça.
Allemagne et Belgique,
ça peut être confondu en vrai,
parce qu'ils mélangent
les mêmes couleurs.
Le noir, le rouge et le jaune,
mais c'est pas dans le même ordre
et c'est pas dans le même sens.
Alors moi je me dis,
la Belgique a les bandes
dans le même sens que nous.
Et je me dis que
si on se ressemble,
c'est parce qu'on parle
le français dans les deux pays.
Et le jaune, il est au milieu.
Parce que dans Belgique,
au milieu de Belgique,
il y a le "J" de jaune.
Le "ge" de Belgique, jaune,
ça se ressemble.
Donc c'est au milieu de Belgique
donc c'est au milieu du drapeau.
Et pour le fait que
ça commence par du noir,
je me dis que
c'est un pays du nord.
Et dans le nord,
on allait miner le charbon.
Donc en fait ça commence
par le noir du nord, du charbon.
Et après il y a le jaune au milieu
et après on finit par le rouge.
Et cette astuce, de commencer par
le noir pour le charbon, qui dans le nord
ça marche aussi
pour l'Allemagne,
qui du coup, n'a pas les bandes
dans le même sens.
Parce qu'on parle pas
la même langue.
Donc ça commence
par le charbon, c'est dans le nord.
L'ordre des couleurs,
c'est ensuite l'inverse de la Belgique.
J'ai pas besoin
de le retenir plus que ça,
je sais que c'est pas
dans le même sens que la Belgique.
On trace directement
sur le drapeau de l'Espagne.
Il porte les armoiries du pays,
ça fait royalisme même si
l'Espagne c'est plus royaliste.
Ils ont quand même un roi,
donc ça ça m'aide.
Il y a du rouge de tous les côtés
et le jaune du sud,
plein de soleil qui prend plus de place
que le rouge, qui est en plein milieu,
c'est comme ça
que je vais m'en rappeler.
Luxembourg.
Ce qui a fait que vous-même,
vous vous êtes pris la tête
dans les commentaires
de ma vidéo, des agents secrets.
Et c'est normal, parce que déjà
il y a le drapeau civil.
Des bandes bleues et blanches
avec le lion rouge.
Et le drapeau mondial.
C'est celui qu'on va retenir,
qui est identique
à celui des Pays-Bas.
Mais avec des teintes
plus claires.
C'est pour ça que même vous,
vous aviez un doute.
Alors là, pour moi
c'est hyper facile.
Luxembourg,
c'est le drapeau Français
qu'on fait pivoter de
90 degrés sur la gauche.
Donc je me dis,
si je vois le drapeau français
qui est renversé, il est lu en biais.
Il est lu en biais, il est Luxembourg,
il est lu en biais.
C'est hyper tiré par les cheveux.
Mais plus c'est tiré par les cheveux,
plus le cerveau s'en souvient.
Et encore une fois,
ne retenez pas par cœur
ce que je suis
en train de vous dire.
Le seul but, c'est vraiment de créer
des connexions dans le cerveau
pour reconnaître les drapeaux
quand on les voit
dans notre vie de tous les jours.
Et quand vous avez besoin
de réactiver les connexions,
parce que vous sentez que
vous les perdez un peu,
vous avez juste à regarder
cette vidéo en accéléré.
Et c'est reparti
pour quelques mois.
L'Andorre techniquement,
c'est comme la Belgique,
mais ça commence par du bleu.
Et moi je me dis,
que quand on dort.
On dort, le ciel est bleu foncé
parce qu'il fait nuit, quand on dort.
Donc pour moi,
Andorre et Belgique
c'est les mêmes.
Mais j'en ai un au nord,
qui commence par le noire du charbon
et l'autre au sud, en bleu.
Parce qu'on dort, en Andorre.
Et enfin on termine avec Monaco.
Monaco c'est pas loin de l'Italie,
mais c'est un tout petit pays.
Donc il n'a pas trois bandes,
mais il a que deux.
Les deux dernières de l'Italie.
Le rouge et le blanc.
Donc c'est proche de l'Italie,
mais c'est sans le début
parce qu'il est petit.
Okay.
ça la première partie
c'est terminé.
On est sûr maintenant, de reconnaître
n'importe quel drapeau
d'un pays qui est voisin avec
la France métropolitaine.
D'ailleurs, on va se faire
un test à la fin de la vidéo.
C'est pour ça que là,
j'ai plein de drapeaux
qui ont été préparés et tout.
Pour voir si moi aussi, ça a tenu
et si vous aussi ça a tenu.
Parce que blague à part,
je suis vraiment en train
de découvrir des drapeaux,
comme Andorre ou Luxembourg.
Que j'avais pas du tout
en tête jusqu'à aujourd'hui,
je ne les connaissais pas,
j'avoue tout.
Okay, je sais pleins de choses,
dans pleins de domaines,
mais ça je savais pas.
Partie numéro deux.
Maintenant on va
élargir à l'Europe.
Donc ça c'est la deuxième
et dernière partie, avant le test.
Pays-bas, c'est comme
le Luxembourg mais plus foncé,
parce que c'est plus au nord.
Tu sais le noir du charbon
tout ça, tout ça.
Je me dis plus on monte,
plus c'est foncé.
Et ça, je vais le lier
au drapeau de la Croatie,
qui a un écusson
comme l'Espagne.
Alors je me dis, la Croatie
c'est le plus au sud de ces trois là,
qui sont liés ensemble.
Et comme il est au sud
comme l'Espagne,
il a un écusson comme l'Espagne.
Donc Luxembourg, Pays-Bas, Croatie,
c'est le même drapeau.
Tout part du Luxembourg.
Si c'est plus foncé, c'est au nord,
donc c'est les Pays-Bas.
Si il y a un écusson,
c'est au sud, c'est la Croatie.
La Pologne,
c'est Monaco en inversé.
Du coup je me dis :
Monacologne.
Alors je ne sais pas
pourquoi je me dis ça.
Mais je trouve que ça marche
bien le mot Monacologne,
je peux pas oublier ça.
Et au fond de moi,
je sais juste que c'est inversé.
Et en fait c'est
tout l'intérêt de relier ça
aux drapeaux qu'on a vu
dans la première partie.
Comme on les connaît,
on n'a pas besoin de rentrer
de nouvelles données,
on peut faire des références.
Donc Monacologne.
Maintenant on s'en rentre
quatre d'un coup,
Danemark, Norvège,
Suède et Finlande.
On va se les rentrer
en une seule fois.
ils sont quatre,
ils sont tous les quatre
identiques dans la construction,
avec une grande croix au milieu.
Et une croix ça a quatre branches,
donc c'est les quatre pays
du nord-ouest de l'Europe,
qui ont une grande croix
à l'ouest de leur drapeau.
ça c'est facile.
Voilà ce que je me dis:
Dans Finlande, il y a le son 'en'
de blanc, Finlande.
Donc le fond blanc,
c'est pour la Finlande.
Suède, ça sonne
un peu comme tiède.
Et pour moi la couleur tiède
c'est le jaune,
parce que le rouge c'est chaud.
Le jaune c'est tiède
et c'est au milieu.
Donc suède c'est tiède,
c'est la croix jaune.
Danemark, ça me fait penser
dans le son final, à Monaco.
A cause du son "ca".
Danemark, Monaco.
Donc je me dis les mêmes
couleurs que drapeau de Monaco.
ça ce sera forcément le Danemark.
Et ensuite, il reste la Norvège.
Trois syllabes,
pas de son en "en".
Donc c'est la croix
qui a trois couleurs,
puisque trois syllabes,
trois couleurs.
Et comme il n'y a pas
de son en "en",
je sais que je vais pas confondre
avec celui de la Finlande.
Royaume-Uni, je pense sincèrement
que personne ici n'a de doute.
Irlande, c'est comme l'Italie,
mais c'est plus clair.
Parce que comme c'est au nord,
il fait un peu plus froid.
Donc Irlande, Italie
ça se ressemble.
Mais les couleurs
sont plus froides, plus pastel.
Portugal, je vous avoue
que jusqu'à aujourd'hui
je ne connaissais pas le drapeau
du Portugal et je m'en excuse,
maintenant je le connais.
Il y a un écusson au sud,
comme l'Espagne.
Je me dis voilà,
tout ce qui est vers le sud
a des écussons souvent.
Et le fait qu'il y ait
deux couleurs comme ça,
ça me fait penser
aux lunettes 3D.
Vous savez, c'est les lunettes
3D de réalité virtuelle.
Et on dit souvent de la VR
et c'est du vert et du rouge.
Vert et rouge.
Donc si j'ai les deux couleurs
VR et l'écusson,
je sais que c'est
le Portugal maintenant.
Mais encore une fois,
je vous le rappelle,
mais on n'apprend pas
les drapeaux par cœur.
On apprend seulement
à les reconnaître,
si on en voit dans la rue
ou sur un écran par exemple.
C'est ça qu'on va tester.
Bon blague à part,
on est déjà à 20 drapeaux.
Donc on va rentrer encore
quelques-uns et après on fait le test.
Russie, Slovénie, Slovaquie,
c'est la même configuration.
Le blanc, le bleu, le rouge,
à l'horizontale.
Donc je me dis qu'en Russie,
j'ai pris trop de vodka.
Et du coup en marchant,
je suis tombé en avant ce coup-ci.
Désolé pour le cliché de la vodka,
mais je vous ai dit les clichés,
c'est ce qui aide
à la mémorisation.
Donc je tombe en avant,
donc c'est le drapeau français
qui tombe en avant.
Mais je suis tombé tellement fort
que le bleu est descendu d'un cran.
Donc ça fait blanc, bleu, rouge.
Parce que le blanc,
il est descendu un petit peu.
Si vous trouvez ça
bizarre tant mieux.
Parce que ça va vous aider
encore une fois à le retenir.
Alors après, s'il y a
un écusson, c'est au sud.
Donc c'est Slovénie ou Slovaquie.
S'il y a une croix, je me dis que
je sais que c'est la Slovaquie.
Parce qu'il y a le son "que"
dans croix et dans Slovaquie.
Et s'il y a pas ça,
s'il n'y a pas la croix,
je sais que c'est la Slovénie.
En gros je me dis :
Si il y a le son "que" c'est la Slovaquie,
sinon c'est la Slovénie.
Et je vais quand même
rajouter l'Autriche
dans cette boucle de mémoire,
parce que c'est entre ces deux pays.
Et c'est un peu le même drapeau,
sauf que au début et à la fin,
on triche pour mettre
la même couleur.
Quand c'est quasiment
le même drapeau mais qu'on triche,
c'est l'Autriche.
Et je termine avec le logo YouTube,
parce que ça pour moi clairement,
c'est le logo YouTube, c'est le player.
Et quand je vois ce player,
je me dis :
Ah il faut que je checke
l'onglet abonnement.
Et s'il faut que "tchèque"
c'est la République Tchèque.
ça nous fait donc 25 drapeaux
pour le moment,
en seulement ce temps là.
Merci Loïc de penser
à rajouter le timer.
Je précise parce que
vous avez quand même retenu
50% du continent Européen,
sur ce temps là.
Si vous le doublez, vous aurez
tout le continent Européen.
Et vous avez déjà retenu presque
14% de tous les drapeaux mondiaux.
Donc si vous voulez continuer
à absorber des drapeaux,
vous voyez c'est pas très long.
Il faut trouver
une fausse logique dedans,
il faut se la dire,
il faut pas chercher à mémoriser.
Il suffit que vous mettiez
une logique derrière, la conscientiser,
de repasser dessus
de temps en temps.
Moi qui suis vraiment éclaté,
au niveau de connaître les drapeaux.
On va voir ce que
ça donne maintenant.
J'ai demandé à Jérémy
de me préparer les drapeaux,
de les découper là dedans,
de mettre des pièges.
Et là il m'a fait des petits cartons
numérotés de un à 27.
Parce qu'il y a les pièges,
qui me permettront de vérifier
si jamais j'ai un doute
ou un truc comme ça.
Donc il y a deux drapeaux aussi,
qu'on n'a pas vu aujourd'hui,
qui sont au milieu de ça.
Donc évidemment, vous le faites
en même temps que moi.
Je vous fais voir les drapeaux.
Et vous me dites
dans les commentaires,
combien vous en aviez,
si vous avez fait
des erreurs, lesquelles.
Même si vous avez
d'autres astuces pour retenir,
ça peut être intéressant.
Donc c'est parti
dans le chaudron de Harry !
Je prends un drapeau au hasard.
Je vous le fais voir
à vous d'abord.
Okay, c'est dans ce sens là.
Donc là pour moi
c'est le bleu nuit.
Donc je sais que c'est le bleu
où je dors, on dort.
On dort en Andorre,
je suis certain, ça c'est Andorre.
Là c'est comme l'Italie
mais c'est un peu plus froid,
parce que c'est l'Irlande.
Vous vous souvenez,
l'Irlande, Italie, c'est pareil.
Mais il est un peu plus froid.
Je vais essayer d'aller
ni vite, ni trop lentement.
Bon là c'est l'Espagne,
on se souvient.
Il y a le soleil au milieu
qui prend beaucoup de place,
avec l'écusson royaliste
parce qu'ils ont un roi.
Qui nous donne d'ailleurs le truc,
quand c'est dans le sud,
il y a souvent un écusson.
Là c'est quoi ?
Ah, c'est dans le même sens
que la France,
donc ça parle français,
c'est la Belgique.
Et ça commence
par le noir du charbon, du nord.
Comme ça je suis sûr,
il y a le "J" de jaune au milieu.
ça c'est au cas où j'ai des doutes,
en fait le but c'est vraiment,
quand on voit un drapeau,
de le dire avec assurance.
Sans passer pour un débile
comme moi l'autre jour,
dans la vidéo agent secret.
Okay ça, il y a une croix
au nord-ouest,
donc je sais que c'est
l'un des quatre pays du nord-ouest.
Et c'est Monacologne,
parce que...
Non c'est pas Monacologne.
ça c'est le Monacologne,
c'est deux fois les mêmes couleurs.
Donc c'est un des quatre, j'ai dit.
Il y a du rouge et du blanc,
mais Monacologne,
je sais que ça marchait, Danemark !
C'est à cause du son 'ca".
Monaco et Danemark,
ça c'est le Danemark.
Cool, c'est retenu.
Là, même combat, s'il y a du blanc,
ce coup-ci je sais que c'est la Finlande.
Parce que blanc.
ça marche bien en fait.
Bleu, okay.
Pour moi, on l'a pas vu ce drapeau.
Quasiment certain
qu'on l'a pas vu.
Je pense que c'est l'un des fakes.
Bleu, Blanc, Rouge.
ça, ça va.
Celui-là, je l'ai, c'est la France.
Merci.
Là on a blanc, bleu, rouge.
Donc je sais que
je suis tombé en avant,
que du coup je tombais fort
et que le bleu est tombé d'un cran.
Donc je sais que c'est la Russie.
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'écusson,
donc c'est pas au sud.
C'est cool, je me suis
upgardé le crâne, Lolo.
Okay, lui se tient du coup,
dans ce sens là.
Donc rouge et blanc,
c'est Monaco.
Parce que c'est à côté de l'Italie,
mais comme c'est un tout petit pays,
il y a moins de trucs.
ça c'est le Royaume-Uni.
Pas besoin de truc.
Okay, blanc, bleu, rouge,
avec un écusson.
C'est comme la Russie,
mais c'est plus au sud.
C'est la Slovénie ou la Slovaquie.
Mais comme il n'y a pas de croix,
c'est la Slovénie.
Rouge, blanc, bleu ?
Ah oui oui, rouge, blanc, bleu.
C'est notre drapeau
mais tourné 90 degrés, en fait.
On l'a lu de biais,
donc ça c'est le Luxembourg.
ça Monacologne,
c'est la Pologne du coup.
ça, rouge, blanc, bleu plus foncé,
du coup c'est les Pays-Bas.
Parce qu'on est
encore plus au nord.
Je suis content, j'espère que
ça marche aussi bien pour vous.
Là on a donc le bleu
qui est descendu d'un cran,
en se cassant la gueule.
Donc c'est comme la Russie,
mais comme il y a la croix ici,
on sait que c'est la Slovaquie !
Ici c'est la Suisse,
on le connaît c'est carré,
sinon on est tout rouge
si c'est pas carré.
Là c'est le player, faut que
je checke mes vidéos Loïc.
Donc c'est République Tchèque.
Merci Loïc.
Ici, il y a deux couleurs.
C'est la VR, vert et rouge,
réalité virtuelle avec l'écusson,
c'est au sud, c'est le Portugal.
Je suis jamais allé au Portugal.
Noir, rouge, jaune,
c'est des couleurs mélangées
de la Belgique et c'est retourné,
parce qu'on parle pas pareil,
c'est l'Allemagne.
Là il y a les trois couleurs,
c'est la Norvège, trois syllabes.
Ici il y a le jaune au milieu,
c'est tiède le jaune.
Donc c'est la Suède.
Suède, tiède.
Là on a rouge, blanc, bleu
avec l'écusson milieu, c'est la Croatie.
Parce que c'est dans ma triptyque
Luxembourg, Pays-Bas, Croatie.
Mais comme il y a l'écusson,
c'est au sud donc c'est la Croatie.
Ici c'est l'Italie,
on a le pesto qui finit en bolo
avec la crème fraîche au milieu.
Ici, blanc, vert, rouge,
on ne l'a pas vu celui-là.
Je pense que c'est un des fakes.
Oh, on triche.
On a mis deux fois
la même couleur.
Si on triche, c'est l'Autriche.
Okay, du coup j'ai pas vérifié.
je vais juste vérifier
si le 25 et le 12,
c'est bien deux drapeaux
qu'on n'avait pas vu
et qu'on sache
lesquels c'est du coup.
Le 12, c'était le
Liechtenstein, voilà.
Du coup on va le mémoriser,
tant qu'à faire.
Et 25, c'était le ?
Ah la Bulgarie.
Okay.
Bulgarie, ça rime un peu avec Italie,
c'est les mêmes couleurs.
Il y a moyen de se faire un délire
un peu comme la Russie,
par rapport à la France.
Un drapeau qu'on retourne
en Bulgarie et tout.
Bon c'est cool.
Voilà comment on a retenu
en quelques minutes à peine,
sans chercher à retenir
quoi que ce soit.
La moitié des pays
du continent Européen.
Et vous pouvez pousser,
pour du coup vraiment avoir
tout le continent Européen.
Dites-moi comment
ça s'est passé pour vous le test.
Si c'était aussi fluide que moi,
si vous avez des astuces
pour retenir les drapeaux des pays
qu'on a pas encore
cité dans la vidéo,
ça peut être cool de les avoir
en commentaires aussi.
Même pour moi,
je regarderai ça.
J'espère que
cette nouvelle vidéo,
de débloquer
une compétence vous a plu.
Prochaine fois, c'est une
compétence de mentalisme.
Pensez à vous abonner, c'est gratuit.
Je m'appelle toujours
Fabien Olicard,
mettez un like à cette vidéo.
N'hésitez pas
à partager tout ça.
Ici, je vous mets deux vidéos.
Là c'est comment débloquer
le fait de faire des rêves lucides
et là c'est comment
débloquer la compétence
de savoir réciter, pas résider,
l'alphabet à l'envers.
Z,Y,X,W,V,U,T,S, etc.
Prenez soin de vous,
à très bientôt.
Ciao.